[Music]
today's question comes from cali in ohio
i'm a teacher and i have a two-year-old
child my husband and i are working on
baby step two and should have our debt
paid off in 23 months after we get out
of debt we plan on having a second child
i would love more than anything to quit
my job and stay at home but my husband
is not on board i make two thousand
dollars a month and getting out of debt
will save us 1400 a month our budget
would be tight but doable how do i
convince him to let me stay at home
this is a good one
so so my first question if if cali were
here and i could ask her a follow-up i
would be curious what their current
child care situation is because often
people dismiss the it can can be
exorbitant cost of child care 100 yeah
and when women choose to stay home it's
not right for everybody but for those
who want to do that and it's right for
them
often them staying home is saving them
more in childcare than they're making in
their full-time job so it just makes
sense yes for them to do that from a
financial standpoint if that's all
you're looking at so i'm just curious
i'm assuming a parent or someone is
watching this child and would watch the
second child so they're basically
getting free child care which is why
that extra income makes a difference but
um but looking at the cost of child care
sometimes it's not just that but man
i've noticed with matt rachel he is so
factual and so logical that i can i can
talk at the feelings level and he's just
like hmm okay but when i talk number
words when i talk numbers yeah he seems
to like that yeah he connects more so i
would say that looking at the numbers
and talking about that now if that's not
an equation um one of the things that
i've always um done in my in any
conversation for that matter is you
really speak to the why
why you want to why it's important to
you
and that can can again bring a deeper
level to the communication to the
discussion versus staying at the surface
where people kind of miss each other
absolutely and i think that that
connection point is key and so for you
guys
yeah i think you're right mapping out
the numbers which i think is one way to
get a husband on board of just getting
out of debt that's the question we have
a lot is how do i get my how do i get my
husband on board or my spouse on board
but when you just look at the time frame
you realize okay it's not that long
in the grand scheme of life right maybe
two three years 18 months
to really buckle down and get rid of
this debt and then when it when you are
debt free it does free up the options
and it does free up and what she was
saying of how much they'd save a month
versus what she makes a month i'm like
man you could still quit your job yeah
and be able to save that amount of money
when you don't have the payments and so
it is it's a it's a it's a
it's such a family values
conversation as well and there's not a
right or wrong in it right like what
you're saying um of the stay-at-home
portion and so you guys getting on the
same page and again talking about your
why i think is is so important well the
other thing that i think is is good and
matt might roll his eyes if he heard me
say this but i think just continuing to
revisit the conversation don't look at
us i'm gonna have this conversation once
we don't agree so then we're just at a
standstill matt and i when we have had
things that we disagree on everything
from big things to small things small
stupid stuff like where we put the fence
in our yard like right we just circle
back to it circle back to it discuss it
you know look at it through other angles
what are your concerns what are my
concerns is there a common ground
when you just continue to work through
it oftentimes you will find how you can
come together but if you see it as well
we talked one time six years ago and he
said no right well we gotta be a little
more persistent than that we gotta keep
working on it care enough about your
relationship and being on the same page
and this decision to continue to work
through it and try absolutely